so go ahead Deb you move alright yeah  first I want to take a moment mister  because we can actually finally show off  the entire character roster ooh there it  is so all the people that have their  little clipart paste it in there you can  actually now use the screen mm-hmm yeah  so today Pete you had a big the big hand  and working on two characters with up  with the design team yes  that being kenchi yes back edges back  and so when you blade that's right now  Ken she's been very much rumored to be  in the game we haven't we've kind of you  know alluded to and got a lot of  screenshots from the mobile game today  we're going to show you how can she  works luckily we have ready here yeah is  one of the guys we play with every day  at work graze at Ken she made when you  say yeah absolutely Ken she is probably  my favorite character named Ken I've  been getting my ass whooped by Ray  lately and I'm trying guys so we're  gonna start with itchy excellent  you